what we knew was that
tony shea had passed away from
complications
um due to inhaling smoke from a fire
the fire happened nine days before he
passed away
and there were a lot of questions about
you know what led up to the fire
what happened within that week and a
half um and
there was just some unclear language
about the announcement
and so we were just sort of monitoring
social media and meanwhile my editors
were telling us that there's probably
more of a story to be told here
some things just didn't seem to happen
and and something that our
editor-in-chief randall lane
was pushing was you know we need to
really understand exactly what happened
here and
you know do this in a way that talks
about who
tony is we wanted to be the the
publication that was writing about it in
a very thoughtful
way because you know you had this
towering figure who
made profound changes on on business
on leadership on the way that you run
companies on like
just even how you live life and we
thought that that message and the
untimely and unseeming
uh death just made for a story that we
needed to
tell right tony shea was a tech
visionary who started a few companies
very early on in his career but
what he's most known for is really being
the ceo of zappos which is an online
shoe retailer
that um was a lot more popular in the
early 2000s
and he's best known for selling that
company to amazon
in 2009 for 1.2 billion dollars so we
essentially
scraped the entire internet for any
sources that had any connection to tony
um and once we had built up you know a
solid source list then we just reached
out to everyone that we could
zappos core values are an obsession
embrace change be humble
create fun and a little weirdness so
it's no secret
that tony liked to blend work
and fun in his life um he would always
be
at the late night parties we had one
source who told us
you know as we got older we would all be
in bed by 9 30 so we can catch
you know the earliest head talk the next
morning while tony would stay up for the
after parties
this year was decisive i think in tony's
life because when these events
ended um it really gave tony a reason
to move out of las vegas this place that
he had built a family and a home and
community to park city you know when he
moved he
made outreaches to certain friends
and said you know i'll pay you double
your highest w-2
if you just would move with me um
and just have fun he supposedly did not
use phones or computers you couldn't
really email him
if you wanted to get in touch with tony
it was either either through snail mail
or you got in touch with another person
who was around him who did have a phone
tony was surrounded by
people who you know were more or less
yes people
um you know many of them were on his
payroll
and many of them weren't necessarily
there or incentivized to
try and stop him or prevent him from
you know harming or engaging activity
that
was you know not healthy for his
lifestyle
one of the uh behaviours that concerned
some
who were with tony in the last several
months was
he taking a keen interest in biohacking
which is effectively this practice
where you try to alter
the performance of your body this meant
going for
extended ice bars going for long runs in
the snow
another bag that came up was that he was
trying to hack sleep
and and how much he was sleeping and
trying to make him sleep less
while you know still performing as a
normal human
um and one of the ways that he was you
know
apparently trying to do this was through
the use of nitrous oxide
from from my understanding of it what
nitrous does is it cuts
oxygen off your brain and so
during that moment when oxygen is
completely cut off you sort of um
might experience this moment of
lightheadedness
that could be associated with euphoria
jewel visited tony at park city
and there were a few purposes to the
visit um
she played a small acoustic set for a
group of 50 people
when she arrived in park city she talked
about her non-profit
um but you know it was also scheduled so
that they could
hang out and you know have a good time
together
but according to sources jewell
basically left park city within a day
she mailed a letter to tony
and this letter talked about how she was
very concerned about his behavior
concerned about his drug use and she
said that you know
you cannot hack sleep you can't not have
sleep and
the amount of nitrous oxide that you're
doing is alarming
and when i read that letter i realized
that this was
this was a big part of the story because
everything that jewel wrote was exactly
what all of tony's friends had told us
and told us that they were trying to
tell tony
but just couldn't get through to him
jewell posted a video to her social
media reacting to tony's death
death is so shocking i don't know how
other people feel about it
but the brain can't comprehend why you
can't just
call
that person anymore once we hit publish
in the story and i read it again
i it did make me just take a second to
think of
people in my own life who i felt that
there are
parallels to tony's story and
you know where there are warning signs
even though people may seem happy and go
lucky and
only spread positivity on the outside
they can be human on the inside and
maybe struggling with things that
not all can see i'm not gonna lie this
was definitely
a fairly emotional reporting process
because
you're talking to friends who are
experiencing the grief
of having lost someone they're close to
and not only that they're recounting
memories that
are painful and
as a reporter of course you don't feel
good about
asking them to relive these memories
right because
i think all of these friends of tony
they wanted to remember
tony from a different year i think
what resonated with a lot of sources was
that we were not trying to write another
tabloid piece
um we read the tabloid pieces and we
felt that
that didn't capture the full story if
any story at
all and i think it was really like being
able to connect with the sources
in the sense that we're not trying to
diminish tony's legacy
we're actually trying to preserve it
while being as
truthful as we can um was what i think
connected with sources the most